hello
and welcome to code talk with your hosts
josh block
and bob lee we're click
and hack the type it brothers
so if any of you have not yet seen a
puzzlers presentation
here's how they work we are going to
show you five brand new
java programming puzzlers see how i
popped my p
i'm making the job hard for the sound
man and um
each puzzle is a short java program
that doesn't necessarily do what it
appears to do
and i'm gonna show it to my brother and
he's gonna try and
figure out what it does and then we will
reveal
the mystery but it's not all fun and
games each of these has a moral
associated with it
and that moral will teach you how to
avoid the trap and you can take that
knowledge back to your job
or your school and avoid the bug forever
so why don't i start today
this puzzle we call the first among
equals and in this puzzle what we're
doing is we're making
a table mapping strings to numbers i'll
let you figure out what they really are
and then we're just going to count how
many of the strings
made it into the table all right let's
take a closer look
we have a main method um we're declaring
an
array of strings it says i came
i saw i left and something that
strikes me is that we have uh the letter
i repeated three times or the word i
it's both and then we create a hash
table
that maps strings to integers and we
call it first
index and then we loop
through the entire array
oop and it's i notice that it's from the
end from the last element
to the first element and for each
element
we put the string at that index
we map the string at that index to that
index
so basically what this is going to do
it's going to start at the rightmost
string and it's going to work its way
left
it's going to put left and
how long is this 0 1 2 3 four five it's
going to map
left to five it's gonna map
i to four it's going to map saw to three
oh and then it's gonna remap i to two
so basically what this is doing oh i see
why you named it first among equals now
because it returns the first index for a
given word that's basically what this
table is
and the words are equal to each other
and those words are equal to each other
so we're going to
we're going to get zero i is going to be
mapped to zero
and then we have a int called nmap and
we're looping over all of the words
again
and each time we see one of the words in
the map
we are going to increment this value so
this value i submit
is going to be the same as the number of
words in the table which was as we saw
six so one two three four five six
and then we're going to print out the
value of nmap
so i submit that this puzzle is going to
print out six it's hard to argue with
that
let's see if it's one of our choices ah
yes that would be choice c
let's ask the audience what they think
that this does
so how many of you by show of hands and
participation is mandatory
uh believe that this program won't print
out six
but will print out choice a zero
i see two of you but you're brave three
three brave people
how many brave people think that it'll
print out
four um which somehow it like eliminates
the duplicates or something
uh i would say that's about a quarter or
a third of you put your ends up high so
i can get a good count
third of a oh that's that's a half
that's about a by my account by my
estimation it's a third of a 2 000
person audience
okay that's a thousand of you all right
and
choice c how many people agree with my
brother and think this program prints
six
uh it's a couple dozen of you and then
how many people think none of the above
well clearly all the rest of you um so
the winning choice
would appear to be choice b4 right
let's find out what it really does shall
we
oh fancy what yeah zero
the intuition and the two or three of
you brave souls
pat yourself on the back um the
intuition here is that the hash table
contains method just doesn't do what you
want it to
let's see what it actually does see here
we're declaring this as a hash table and
calling its contains method
and if you look it up under hash table
it says test
if some key maps into the specified
value value in the hash table so this
better be of value the values
are all integers but we're running
through the strings the possible keys
and of course the keys are not found in
the value position
so that that's awful isn't it yeah what
do we do about it well
i'm glad you asked me the first thing
you do is you
follow the advice in effective java i'm
sure you all have copies of that book
and you always have two excellent i have
two as well the old edition and the new
edition
um and i you declare collections using
their interfaces
not not their implementations that's
silly and once
you do that well gosh your ide won't
even let you screw
up intellij will say whoa you know it
won't even suggest contains because
that's not
a method on map it's a it's a kind of a
an
old hash table method that you shouldn't
be using
anymore what if you don't use an ide you
mean if your rocket old school with
emacs like i sometimes do
um well then java c will tell you that
you screwed up
with this fine error message and then
once you've been told that you're a fool
you go like this do
and you fix it you write what you wanted
to write which is contains key
right makes sense and that that's what
your id will suggest for you
you'll do it and then it'll print six
just as my brother bob
said it should so what's the moral of
this story we got a couple morals
first moral is always
declare collections using their
interface types
so map from string to integer equals new
hash map
for api designers don't violate the
principle of least astonishment
which states that every method call
should be the least astonishing thing
given its name
if i got a hashtag i'll ask does it
contain harry
you know it's astonishing that it's
looking in the values rather than the
keys so that does violate the principle
at least astonishment you'll know that
you violated it if your
api users say what exactly exactly
well said um and and by the way don't
don't use hash table anymore hash table
is pretty much obsolete
if you're using the thing um serially
then
use hash map and if you're using it
concurrently
use concurrent hashmap it scales like
nobody's business it's a wonderful class
you can run
you know thousands of threads against it
and it just works it's fast
dougly wrote it i need to say no more
cool that was tricky but if you think
that was tricky i have one for you
all right i call it proxy fight and we
have this cute little kitty
and we love her so much that we are
going to use serialization to create a
copy of her
and then we're going to check our
results any standard design
pattern that this demonstrates for us uh
yes we don't want to serialize the kitty
directly
serialization proxy serializable so we
use the serialization proxy pattern
right
right yes it's it's some book i read
about it i swear i did
anyway all right so um let's take a look
at it
and by the way these are adorable little
proxy cats
um so what do we do
well the first thing we do i see cat
implements serializable
and then which means we can you know
store it and read it back in
uh and we have a write replace method um
write replace as you guys may know it
basically nominates a candidate
to be serialized instead of the object
the so-called proxy
you know because you might want to not
actually serialize the poor little
pussycat himself
you get a better representation of the
pussycat that's the proxy
and that's what is serialized and then
when you deserialize it
you have a read resolve method
on the proxy that is serialized and it
basically
turns the proxy back into the cat so
let's take a look
um what does the write replace do it
simply creates a new proxy object
nothing could be simpler than that
that's kind of you know about as simple
as this pattern can get
um and the proxy class itself how does
it look
well uh once again it's got nothing i
see no fields there at all
um and when a proxy comes in
you simply create a new a new
cat so basically if you serialize a cat
it emits one of these proxy cats
and when you deserialize it you get a
brand new cat now let's look at the main
method and see what it does
uh we got a bite array output stream
equals new byte
output stream so that's what you do when
you're testing serialization
you serialize it into like a byte array
and then out so you don't have to worry
about any files or anything it's the
easiest way to test serialization
um we get an original cat called uh
a new cat so that's good and now
we take our bite away output stream
we wrap it into an object output stream
so we can actually write the cat to it
and then we call right object um
on this shouldn't say new cat this
should say original
pretend this says original there's a bug
on this slide that we just discovered
now
[Laughter]
all right and now yeah exactly
um now we we de-serialize him how do we
do that
well we take the byte array um
and sorry we take the bite array output
stream
we call two byte array to get its fight
array out of it get the bytes
and we can tell that whoever designed
this api really fell in love with the
gang of four design or a gang of four
decorator pattern
yes yes yes too many decorators now we
wrap
the byte array in a byte array input
stream and we wrap that in an
object input stream so we can pull
objects out of it and we do pull an
object out of it by calling read object
and we know that the object is a cute
little uh
proxy cat and so we um no actually it
should be a cat
and so we cast it to cat um and that's
the copycat so we have the original cat
and the copycat
finally we print out whether the copycat
equals the original but that's like a no
brainer right because
the proxy always creates a new cat so
we're finding out if
a new cat equals an old cat so actually
bug or not it doesn't matter
this program would print out false okay
let's
see what the audience thinks first of
all again
everyone participate how many people
think the correct answer is
a and that this uh that the equals
method returns true and that the cats
are equivalent
oh we got a couple back there somebody
of your convictions i think there's more
than a couple but they're not raising
their hands high
think about it think about it how many
people think the correct answer is
b and they agree with my brother false
all right ooh that's about a third
quarter i'll give that a quarter
um how many people think the correct
answer is c and that this method throws
an exception
you say that's about half half a third
half something like that
half plus a quarter plus a half dozen i
don't i can't count
how many people think the correct answer
is d none of the above
always a safe choice
but before we proceed to the right they
get lonely if they have no votes are
there no votes because i'm going to
change
my votes if no one knows we have to
change oh we got one for none of the
above one we're going to change the
answers
all right next time and shall we see
what it really does
let's see who got it correct the correct
answer is c
throw is an exception and specifically a
classed cast
exception deep in the bowels of
deserialization
oh well so an intuition here
is and it's not a class cat exception
note
oh a classic acting section
you are clever aren't you so the
intuition here is that write replace
and read resolve fail for circular
references
well let's take a look at this
oh poor proxy proxycat so show me what's
really going on
let's take a closer look so we had this
class but note that this is an
inner class not a static nested class
and as everyone knows an inner class has
an implicit
or an inner inner class instance has an
implicit
reference to its enclosing instance so
this proxy
actually has a reference to the cat
instance
and whenever we go to deserialize our
cat
we fail during the read object method
give me some more details what's really
going on so what's going on here
is that right replace and read resolve
in during serialization they fail
in the presence of circular references
and specifically the way they fail
is that when you're serializing
something this java serialization
framework will call
write replace on all instances even
circularly
referenced instances however when you go
to deserialize this proxy
it is not symmetric java serialization
will call
read resolve on the outermost instance
but when you have a nested instance
it doesn't bother and worse it tries to
take
this proxy object and store it in a
field of type cat
and it fails spectacularly with that
weird class cast exception and what
makes this particularly insidious
is that things serialize just fine
and you don't actually find out about
the problem until perhaps weeks later
or months or months later when you try
to deserialize this and realize that
your data has been corrupted
lost forever lost forever that that is a
sad story
this has to be a bug what's the spec
have to say about all this uh this is
actually
by design um design
you call it design okay they might have
wrote the code first and then baked this
into the spec
when somebody complained about it this
is a good way i'll bet
someone like filed a bug and then they
fixed the bug by writing this into the
spec
i'll bet let's read the prose and then
we'll move on all right
so specifically the spec says that in
cases where an object being serialized
nominates a replacement object whose
object graph has a reference to the
original object that is our proxy to our
cat
deserialization will result in an
incorrect
graph of objects thank you furthermore
if the reference types of the object
being read
the ones nominated by write replace and
the original object are not compatible
say like
cat and boxycat proxy is not assignable
to cat
the construction of the object graph
will raise a class cast exception well
if we just read this
on page 159 of the serialization
spectrum yeah like what is this
spec by show of hands thought so all
right
so simply put read resolve and write to
replace
do not work in the presence of circular
references not with some hoop
jumping so what can we learn from all
this uh
well how do you fix it sorry oh well
first of all the way we fix it
is that we just turned this into a
static nested class as we first intended
it'd be nice if that was a default by
the way
but you just do that by adding static
then we say bye bye to the circular
reference
and our proxy deserializes just fine and
this prints what my brother thought it
would
false because the copycat is different
from the original cad correct
now what can we learn from this a few
things
as we said right replace and read result
don't work on the presence of circular
references
uh also the serialization proxy pattern
does not work in the presence uh if if
the proxy object itself refers back to
the original object like this can happen
if you have a collection and a contain
that you want to serialize and it
contains an object that refers back to
the collection
um there are there are some arcane ways
that you can work around it and if you
want to see them check out mapmaker and
guava
check out the source code and the real
one of the main morals of this story is
always make your serialization proxies
uh
static that is static nested classes and
then furthermore
make sure that you unit test these
things so you don't find about out about
these problems
in production after you've lost your
data and you can't recover it anymore
and for system designers when you're
implementing dear serialization and
deserialization logic and
any type of complementary logic logic
for that matter
make sure that you provide symmetric
behavior so you don't surprise your
users
i beg to differ i think perhaps there's
one more moral here
uh don't use serialization
all right i have one for you and um i'll
tell you in advance it's another hairy
or should i say
furry furry problem like the cat you see
um sorry all right this one is called
creation
miss um and
in in this problem um we have a couple
of imnum classes
representing adam and his
wife eve and all we do
is we check if adam's wife is indeed eve
and if eve's husband is indeed adam and
and
why don't you tell me what the program
prints that seems simple enough
um i'm going to start at the top we have
a new
man with one value named adam
and it passes a value to its constructor
eve and the constructor assigns
that value eve to the wife field which
is
final and we have another enum woman
that has one value
eve and we pass adam to the constructor
and the woman constructor stores
adam in the husband field which is also
final
now let's take a look at the main method
we have a boolean adam has eve
and it checks that adam's wife is equal
to eve
so that'll be true and we have another
boolean eve has adam
that will check that eve's husband is
adam
so that will also be true i submit and
then we print out
these two values concatenated so i think
it will print true
true i suppose it would have to print
that
but let's see if it's one of our choices
ah it's choice a
very good so let's ask the audience what
they think the program prints
how many people agree with my brother
and believe this program does print
true true
what a splattering about four or fives
of you and i should tell you
every night we make it a point almost
every night almost to have
one puzzle that actually does what it
looks like it does though usually for a
different reason
so this could be that puzzle anyway true
true how many votes for true true
hands way up half dozen of you how many
people go for true false choice b
oh another half does that it's like an
even dozen but you don't seem very sure
of yourself
uh how many people go for choice c false
true
oh that's better about about a quarter
of you and how many people think none of
the above
ooh i'd say about um more than a half
well let's find out what it really does
shall we
who's right well it turns out that more
than half of you all right
yep go give yourself a hand no pointer
exception
and the intuition here is that
man and woman have a circular class
initialization
dependency so let's take a closer look
and
unfortunately the only way to analyze
class initialization in detail in java
is to manually
simulate it to just walk through it you
can do it either yourself or you can use
it do it using an ide in this case we're
going to do it
on the screen josh i think you've gone
non-linear
perhaps i have um anyway
so the idea is that initialization
starts from the top and ends at the
bottom
so let us take a look at what happens
first the vm
says hey we're running creation but
there's really nothing to do there in
terms of initializing creation so it
just runs the main method
and the first thing it does there is
it's got to call evaluate
the right-hand side of this assignment
uh it begins with man.adam so we're
looking at the atom field of man that
means we have to initialize the man
class and so we start at the top of the
man
class right and we go up to here and
um the first thing we do there is we're
going to create
an instance of we're going to evaluate
the parameters here create an instance
not create we're going to reference the
eve
field of woman so now we've got to
initialize
woman right so now we go down into woman
and the first thing we're going to do
here is we're going to create eve which
means we have to evaluate
her arguments her man her atom we look
at man.adam
and we say gosh we better initialize the
man class but wait
our thread is already initializing the
man class what do you do
when you have a initialization
circularity like that anyone know
blow up yeah let the audience i heard
them say ignore it so audience gets
credit for this you ignore it you just
blast on through and that's what we do
you read the contents of man.adam
it would get set up here when this line
finished but it hasn't finished yet
so it's kind of pre-initialized anyone
know what the value is when it's
pre-initialized
no it's null so sadly we pass null
into the constructor of of um eve
there and then what does this
constructor do
it stores the null into the husband
field of eve and now we are in
big trouble now that constructor
returns and we
create an atom um and so
we're down here in this constructor and
we properly store
eve into adam's wife field so that's
good um and returning
from that we initialize the atom field
of man but it's too late we've already
read the null out
so even though we're putting the correct
final value that can never change in now
we saw it before the final value was set
well
now we go down to here um we say
read the wife we check if it equals
woman
dot eve and adam's wife in fact was set
to woman.eve
so this returns true as it ought then
we set eve has adam to woman.eve
dot husband which is what null
equals man.adam oops null equals
anything
throws an all-pointer exception and it's
game over so
what do we do to fix it well there's two
ways to fix these things you've got to
break the initialization circularity
one way or another either you do it
manually or with lazy initialization in
this case i've chosen to do it
manually and the way i do it is that
man depends on her woman but not vice
versa
seen relationships like that but anyway
um
so what we do in this case is that
um the man will tell
his own wife that he is her husband
so inside the constructor for man we get
wife.husband equals
this um and so the woman now is very
very simple
the husband field is no longer final
because it's set after the creation of
the woman
and we just wait for our man to tell us
who our husband is so now let's run
through the initialization
again this time through we say man.adam
okay initialize man
we need woman.eve initialized woman well
all we do is set eve equal to a new
woman
no work to do no problems um and then
we create um an instance of adam
and we're calling this constructor we
set our wife to eve
and we set eve's husband to adam
we tell our lucky wife that we are her
husband
finally we return we're back down here
and we check if adam's wife
equals eve it does if eve's husband
equals adam
it does and it prints true true makes
sense wonderful
all right and what can we learn from
this one well
first of all circular dependencies in
class initialization
are dangerous if you have one all hell
can break loose you will see static
fields
in their uninitialized states which is
zero for instance
false for booleans and null for object
references that's like the really bad
one
and these things can infect objects of
those types you can violate
your um you know
it can violate things and all hell
breaks loose enums are particularly
prone to the problem
because they begin with expressions that
create instances of themselves
and the best way around this is keep
your class initialization
simple because java automatically
initializes classes um
you know it's hard enough even if you
keep them simple
if you have any doubts if you think you
might have a circularity
step through it by hand or in your ide
and if you do have a circularity break
it
either using this manual final final
initialization
or lazy initialization i'm a huge fan of
laziness or initialization
specifically in this case we could have
one a new named
person with an abstract method called
get spouse and that would be more
politically correct too by the way yeah
yeah good point all right now i have one
for you
i call this puzzle what's the f
all right josh please consider the
following
wait are you allowed to say that at
strange loop is that allowed
okay good good oh and i see you've got
an f hole up there very nice
all right continue all right consider
these this is a short one
consider these two variable declarations
which of these
com this is a little different than what
we've done so far which of these
compiles
neither one or the other or both
well uh let's let's take a look also uh
let me take a moment to thank alexi
shippelleff who tweeted this puzzle yes
this is the first puzzle we've ever seen
that
began its life as a tweet which is why
it's such a nice short puzzle
all right so this actually looks very
easy because i know
that a short is 16 bits long and
furthermore
i know that a hex digit is four bits
long
so here we're taking four hex digits
which is 16 bits and trying to store
them in a short
so that fits here we're taking eight hex
digits and i see by the way
you've used the underscore which is a
nice java 7 feature let me take a moment
to tell my brother that we're on perfect
time stop looking at your damn watch
buddy
all right so
and um so this is
four times four is 16 bits and we are
trying to shove 16 bits
into sorry 32 bits right 8 times 4 is
32.
so we're trying to shove 32 bits into a
16-bit bag
you can't do that so
this one's illegal and that's one's
legal
so i i would have to say that
a is legal b is not and that would be
choice a
16 bits into a 32-bit bag that's quite
the euphemism
let's see what the audience thinks um
how many people think that the answer is
a
and that a is legal i.e it compiles and
that b
does not
[Music]
about a half dozen more than a half
dozen put your hands way up i
i've got friends out there it doesn't
give me a dozen
all right let's see how many people
think it's b
that b compiles and that a does not
anyone one one guy back there one guy
all right how many think that the answer
is c that both a
and b are legal i think that's 90 of the
audience
it's about right how many does that
leave uh d neither a
nor b compile no it's about quarter
no no it's ten percent ten percent oh
yeah yeah i guess ninety percent plus
all right shall we see what's really
going on here
oh let's let's see the right answer
who's right oh
a b a compiles
but b does not and the impression here
yeah that is perverse
we're initializing short variables with
int literals so let's take another one
let's take another let's take another
i don't believe this let's take a closer
look so first of all
let's look at this value 0x fff
also note that uh short values are
signed
and that their values must be between
negative 32
000 and positive 32 000 and what what is
that that is a 2
negative 2 2 15 2 15 through 2 to the
15th minus one exactly um and then let's
take a look at this first value now note
that both of these things on the right
side here
are int literals and the first one is 0x
fff
which is about 65 000. so it's twice as
big
it's clearly greater than the maximum
sure so then the compiler can tell
at compile time that this shouldn't be
allowed whereas who can tell me
uh well actually this slide can tell me
which what the value
of zero x this literal literal ffff
ffff obviously that's uh with all the
one bits
set and that negative two or two's
complement is negative one which
is a valid short value and the compiler
allows it it's like right in the middle
of the range
so it fits very well yep very
comfortably well how do we fix it
well the fix is simple we just uh
basically with the
the with with the first one we can just
cast it to a short
and this will be an explicit cast and
basically it'll take the bits and assign
them to that short and with the second
one
really what we were doing is we were
trying uh
you know we just make this a little less
misleading basically we were stripping
off
the high order bits in the last example
so in this case it's really equivalent
to assigning it to 0x ffff and also
casting it to a short
so now both but you would have gotten
the same value if you'd left the 16 bits
in there that's exactly right yeah
that's exactly right and what is that
value
uh this is uh so now both declarations
are actually legal now
yeah and and what does it get
initialized to uh which one
both they're the same
negative one negative one that's a nice
number i like it
all right and what can we learn from it
a few things first of all
java lacks short and by literal so we
we're stuck having to assign an intel
literal
to a short um even though we need it uh
and if the intellectual is in the uh is
in the i guess the
allowed range for a short or a byte the
compiler will just silently cast it for
you
yeah and um also just like int
the short and byte types are always
signed which is good
type is always shiny it's not really
what you want yeah
design assigned byte type so to to
obtain a
shorter byte with the high bit set you
actually have to cast
an intellectual or use a negative and
it'll set that bit for you
and notice that like hex binary and
octal literals can be negative
even without the minus sign you notice
we had zero x f f
f and it was actually a negative number
even though there was no minus sign
in that literal so i guess the real
moral of this story is to avoid
short and bite uh because there's
they're painful to use and they're
they're seldom what you want they're
second-class citizens in java they're
they're basically just
deficient ins you almost always want
ants yeah really the only time you would
use them is if you have like a packed
array of shorts or bytes
and then for you know for language
designers provide god's sake
provide literals for all the built-in
types and so you don't
your users don't have to jump through
these hoops um especially for bike for
gas
stakes and then also please provide
unsigned
primitive types by the way to any
language designers in the audience
both of these things could be fixed in
java without breaking anything
we could still add those literals please
do it well let's do it all right
now i have one last short problem for
you i call this one
mad max and this is a
kind of a simple problem
and in this problem we simply
have a method that calculates the max of
its variable number of arguments
and we test it and i want to know what
it prints
let me check it out all right i'm going
to start at the top
we have a static method that returns a
double called max and it takes in
a var args list of double values and so
this is really just an array of doubles
we can we can effectively treat it like
that and on the first line here oh
you're doing something very good you're
checking the preconditions
uh if vals.length is zero that is they
didn't pass in any values because you
can do that with vera arps
we throw an illegal argument exception
and we blow up
quickly with a nice clean error then
in the case where we have one or more
values we assign the result
to double dot min value and then we
iterate
through the values and if a value is
greater than our current result
starting at double dot min value well
then we assign
that value as our new result and at the
end we simply return that result
um let's look down here now in our main
method we
calculate the maximum of negative 1 0
and what's that number
uh that would be negative e negative e
that's unnatural
i suppose it is and clearly
the maximum uh here is zero because
these two numbers are negative
so i submit that this method is going to
print zero
well that makes sense it is the maximum
of its arguments let's
find out what our audience thinks how
many people
agree with my brother that this program
will print 0.0
it's floating point so that's that's the
way it prints it
make sure what else could it be right um
how many people think that this program
will print
4.9 times 10 to the negative 324th
i think you're making these too easy
[Music]
i'd say that's a few dozen of you maybe
35 something like that few crazy people
in the audience uh how many people think
it throws an exception
about the same few dozen and how many
people think none of the above something
else better be a lot of you
you all have to vote let me one last
time i want to get some good numbers
here now we don't have time
so we'll just say what one what's what's
the winning choice
who knows it's it's unclear let's find
out what it really does shall we it was
a tie between c and d
i c and d oh you're both wrong
uh oh it turns out that this program
does indeed print
4.9 times 10 to the minus 324 and the
intuition here is that double dot min
value is very different from integer.min
value
see while integer.min value is the most
negative
int double dot min value is the
positive double with the smallest
magnitude so it's the tiniest it's the
quantum of doubleness
let us say that makes perfect sense it
makes no sense at all
it's terrible
so how do you fix it what is the
equivalent
of integer.min value what is the real
lowest double value
uh negative infinity negative infinity
so you could
say result equals double log negative
infinity and then it would work
but you could do something much better
than that check this out
if you declare it as double first and
then
var args double rest then
it'll blow up at compile time instead of
at runtime if you don't pass in anything
it won't even match the declaration and
moreover you don't need
any sentinel value to initialize the
thing
you simply initialize it to first
iterate over the rest
and if anything is greater than your
candidate you replace the candidate
this again prints 0.0 and i submit to
you and all of you
that this is the correct solution and
what can we learn from this
first of all the least at double value
is double that negative infinity not
double dot min value same is true of
float
second of all if you need one or more of
something
declare it type first type dot dot rest
and this generalizes to two or more
three or more and so forth um for api
designers
don't violate the principle at least
astonishment don't have like
double dot min value an integer.min
value means something completely
different
be consistent in the use of your names
so a summary actually just let me stop
you there for once i think the real
moral of this story is
don't use floating point
yeah especially not for money i would
say so all right
so uh looks like we've got three more
minutes just enough time to finish up
so a summary of the traps that we've
told you about number one
always declare collections using their
interface types number two if a method
requires one or more
args declare it with t first
and then a var args list and this
requires you to pass in at least one
element
number three always declare your
serialization proxy static
or don't use serialization and number
four circular dependencies and class
initialization
are dangerous to break them finish
initialization of one class manually
or lazily number five avoid short and
bite they are painful to use and sell
them what you want
and for system designers language and
api
number one don't violate the principle
of least astonishment two be consistent
in the use of name parts
also known as words yes indeed
and three provide symmetric behavior for
serialization and deserialization and
number four provide literals for all
built-in types
for god's sake and number five
provide unsigned primitive types so
in conclusion java is still
as of java 7 a reasonably simple and
elegant language
hint hint um but it has a few sharp
corners
avoid them the best way to do that is to
keep your program
short and simple and if you aren't sure
what a program does well then it
probably doesn't do what you want it to
do
a good way to find these bugs before
they bite you
is to use a program called find bugs
which you can download from the web
written by
our friend bill pugh and his graduate
students or a fine ide
such as intellij and finally don't code
like my brother
don't code like my brother and if for
some strange reason you actually
liked this talk by
this book and this just in case you have
any doubts is a
plug a shameless look shameless
shameless plug swipe yellow all right
and if you want to like you know contact
us and
you know marriage proposals or we have
we have two endpoints
all right so thank you very much and we
hope to see you again next year
thank you very much